Yeah.
Hey, what's going on? It's Bill Burr.
It's time for the Monday
morning podcast from Monday,
September 3rd,
2018 what's going going on?
How are Ya?
Oh happy Labor Day
to you.
Happy Fucking Labor Day to you.
Whoa.
Happy Fucking
labor.
Day You
so
cubicle dwelling.
cunt,
happy fucking Labor Day to you.
How many fucking podcasts are out there
wishing you a happy Labor Day with an
original song?
Huh?
Am I going to get sued for saying
that in the podcasting world,
in the podcasting stratosphere. Where
are you guys doing today? On Labor Day.
Okay.
What the fuck is Labor Day anyways?
Does this have something to do with the
troops? How hard they're working, right?
And you're not doing shit cause you're
not wearing a uniform, right? Huh?
You fucking civilian piece of shit.
Okay.
Don't you love how that's the vibe now,
how about a round of
applause for our troops?
I am around the plus the rest
of us paying the fucking taxes.
You can't do this God damn field trip
over there and it's never going to fucking
end until what? We bankrupt
the whole fucking thing.
And five have all the money.
How about a round a plus for us?
You rich cuts Julian and scrolling
and leaving us with the fucking tab.
Yeah.
Can I get on the plane first? Every once
in awhile. Your fucking ass. All right.
Labor Day.
Okay.
Fucking me knee here.
Labor Day is a public holiday or a day
of festivities held in honor of working
people in the United States and Canada.
I'll listen about your wife visit.
Oh,
shots fired.
I'm on the first Monday in September
and in many countries on May 1st,
why do we always have to
be different over here?
You know the whole fucking
world's on the metric system. Oh,
fucking world is celebrating
Labor Day on May 1st not America.
Now we're on standards September 1st.
The rest of the world respecting
the summer or at least the spring.
I ain't his shit. You fucking day off
at the end of the goddamned summer. Um,
when you're like,
you got to pack up the water skis.
Hey Buddy.
You know,
that's about the Nath fucking negative
thing you said about the United States of
America. I got one for you.
I, you got a fucking day off.
Why don't you pack your shit
up and get the fuck out?
[inaudible] you like it if
some mother fucking land.
Okay.
Fucking Moscatos the size of
your fucking freckled ball head.
You fucking orange mother fucker.
I got a good fucking mind to get out
of my truck and go ahead and show you
what's what.
Yeah,
happy labored.
Hey,
dear America.
Okay.
Oh, you fucking whining, crying
fucking snowflakes out there
bitching about global warming.
You want to see warming I my fucking nuts,
mother fucker.
I'm a God damn coal miner. You
understand me? I'm a coal miner in 2018.
What a fuck what I want to go out,
learn about solar power where I can
continue doing a fucking job that's out
oxalate.
I don't give a fuck if I'm
digging in a national park.
Stepping on a fucking Bald
Eagle fucking head. All right?
If that's going to put spam on my
fucking table, I'm going to do it.
And at some orange to play
where a motherfucker where
the goddamn read Todd down.
Who's fucking knees going to
do it for me and a God damn.
And I'm going to vote for
dear America.
Um,
yeah.
So you always wonder
what my neighbors think.
Okay.
You know how many people live in that
house in, are any of them in a good mood?
Oh Jesus.
So it's Labor Day.
Now let me ask you a question since
it's a fucking day off, right? Does,
does your wife's give you the day off?
Huh?
Or does she want you to run around and
do a bunch of Goddamn jobs that need to
be done while she stays in the
house doing God knows what.
Right? I was hoping we could get those
boxes there. Is that what you were hoping?
Well God gave you a
couple of arms in a back.
Okay.
Start lifting this weight.
Yeah,
he's fucking ladies. I swear to God it
can you, can you ever just sit down?
Okay.
What is a couch for in their world other
than to throw too many fucking pillows
on it. See, can't even fucking sit down.
And the second year it's like they know
the second year fucking Goddamn assets.
The couch and your head's on the pillow
and you grabbed the remote to watch a
little college football.
What happened?
Yeah.
Hi.
Yeah,
sorry. I am in a mood. I'm
actually happy married guy.
I don't even know why I'm doing this.
I'm just trying to make you guys laugh.
All right. Cause I bet in
those relationship. All right,
my wife's coolest shit though. You know,
the other night I was hanging out, right?
Smoking a Sega, uh Oh no, I
wasn't supposed to hang out.
I ended up just fucking partner called
me up and we ended up hanging out and
she's like, you know, she sent me
the usual texts and I was like,
I'm down the comedy store, I'm
smoking a cigar. Some buddies of mine,
we did a spot, uh, sorry. And she goes,
she goes, now hang out with your friends,
have a good time. And I texted
her back. Best wife ever. Right?
You can't complain if your wife does that
once a fucking year you, you got a gym,
you know, and my wife consistently does
that unless, you know, at two three,
you know,
the next night when I went out again,
that took a little four day vacation is
what I did here as I stayed on my diet.
By the way, I had a couple of
little missteps here or there,
but generally speaking, I've been
drinking a little fucking smoothie here.
You know, I don't know what I'm
doing. I've got to add some cardio,
but you don't accept that I got this
fucking Shit beat out of me by some God
damn bugs. I don't even know where they
always go after my left foot, you know?
I'm like the fucking Daniel Day Lewis,
a bug bites my left foot.
They just go after it
right now it is on fire.
Yeah.
You know,
I literally have to put like some that
oxy 10 on it and then I got to put a sock
on it like so I won't
scratch it. Like, you know,
when you put a fucking the Goddamn I,
someone said chandelier a fucking
lamp shade over dogs fucking,
you know,
so you can't turn around by itself.
The problem is that's why should I just
stick a fucking one of those lampshades
on my uh,
on my ankle.
But the problem is I'm a God damn human
being made in the image of our Lord and
Savior,
Jesus Christ.
So I have the ability to figure out how
to take off said lamp shade and start
scratching the fuck out of my ankle.
It was so bad the other night actually
woke me up like nothing could touch it.
It was on fucking fire and a dude.
These are next level.
These are next level global warming.
Fucking mosquitoes. All right.
If you've got a pair of jeans on or
Dungarees as they used to be called,
they'll bite right through them.
They don't give a shit, you know?
Okay.
I wish I could be some assassin
fucking mosquitoes. Right.
And rather than just bite and regular old
fucking people and given a malaria and
that shit,
like I could just blue,
cool.
Fucking just go find one of
those Bilderberg meetings.
I just find who the fuck is in
front of all his goddamn madness.
Sorry guys. I don't know. This is
why I don't watch the fucking news.
Um,
yeah,
just go on a 100 million fucking miles
an hour into the brick wall and all these
fucking rich people think that somehow
they're going to have a parachute.
And I guess what the rest of
us are all going to die. Is
that what it is? Oh, Bill,
come on. It's a holiday. All right.
All right, let's talk football here.
Let's talk football.
BOMP bomp bomp bomp bomp um,
how about those red sox
lost of the white sox last night,
eight to nothing for the first time.
We're actually kind of playing like 500
ball and I think it's a great thing.
I don't want to go to the
fucking playoffs. Not knowing
what losing feels like.
Like, wait, what's this? Are the wheels
coming off? I wanted to more be like,
oh yeah, this, we got
out of this. All right.
Sales still on the disabled
list as far as I know.
And I don't know if price is a pitch
since he got hit by that comebacker liner
off his wrist. X Rays were negative,
were dealing further fucking studies.
So a, we shall see. We'll see what's
gonna happen. Um, last day. So, um,
the Astros,
the team to beat the defending world
series champions getting zero respect out
there in Houston.
You know,
you would think that the baseball team
was as fat as the average person in
Houston. And, and don't even fucking
wrinkle your Goddamn snout up at me.
If you fucking live in Houston,
you guys went back to back.
You had a goddamn dynasty
of being fucking, uh,
nominated or winning the fattest
city in the United States of America.
All right. And this is the fattest
fucking country evidently. Okay.
You are,
you are a fat person's fatty Houston.
Yeah.
Down there. Fucking barbecue
and everything aren't, you know,
do you know I was just actually
was actually just in Houston,
there is not a p a juice
joint and that entire city
lettuce is illegal. This
is, this is a US city.
Okay.
Now, are you wondering why they
had that Biblical flood down there?
Maybe God was like this.
This is a level of slough
that I have never seen. See,
that's why there's never a
flood out here in Hollywood,
okay?
Because we are so righteous.
We
are so living
day to day
in his image, in his word. I want you all
right now. I want you to close your eyes.
I want you to close your eyes
right now and just know that Jesus,
he wants you to live in Hollywood.
He wants you to go there.
He wants you to do some coke.
He wants you to get a girlfriend,
tried to fuck her friend and try to get
both of them to fuck you at the same
time. He wants that. I'm sorry,
that was my Joel Olsteen.
That's why he didn't open
the Goddamn doors when that,
when that flood fucking came in, just
like, I don't have enough fucking,
what am I fucking Jesus going to keep
pulling out fucking barbecued fish for
these people. I, I don't.
I simply do not have enough
wafers to sustain this.
That's going to be a riot. They can,
they're gonna rip up my blue carpet.
Okay.
Um, he was content to let those
fatties just float right by the arena.
Right. Well, you know what
I would've done? I would've
put some fucking moorings.
Is that what you call those things?
You get dock a boat too.
I would have thrown some rope out there.
And you said those fatties fucking,
you know,
now they're like a bunch of dinghies
until the water came down. I mean,
what was Joel Olsteen supposed to do?
Okay.
Joel Osteen's in shape. He lives
in Houston. You know why that is?
It's America. I, Hey,
I saw the image of a skinny Joe Olsteen
and my pop tart the other day when I was
in downtown Houston.
You ever take two pop tarts or heat
them up and you stick a glaze down in,
in the middle of it? Cause she
don't, you know, live in Houston.
He lay in a bath, this laugh, um,
I to drink smoothies more
before I do a podcast.
I have incredible energy and a new
level of disrespect for a lot of things.
Dude,
my fucking foot,
my fucking foot is driving me nuts.
And then I got,
I got a bug bite on the back of my arm
and then I got another one on my lower
back, like just to the right of
where a tramp stamp would be.
Did I ever tell you guys I was dumb enough
to get one of those in the nineties?
I did. I got a Boston Bruins
stamp. Tramp do, you know,
and I said Real men wear black and I had
that right above my ass and I had to,
I had to work so hard.
I'm sorry,
in stand up to finally be able to
afford enough money to begin my laser
treatments to remove it.
I know a lot of you probably always
wondered why I never wear a half shirt on
stage.
Well that is why.
Okay.
I mean, I guess my big fault
is that I'm a hockey fan. Okay.
There I said it. Um, did you guys
watch any college football yesterday?
How about college football?
Just taking over this weekend.
The way the NFL does
towards the end of the year,
the NFL is give a fuck that you
got Christmas shopping to do.
They don't care that you got
you're Jewish and you got to buy.
Fuck was an eight gifts.
Nine gifts for each fucking person,
right?
Is that candle fucking goes
candle number one. What do
you got? Well, how do you do
what? Jewish people? D a d. A.
D a build the build up the gifts.
That's why you gotta do it, right?
You gotta start with the
weakest thing you got right.
What do you guy got a pair of socks,
you know,
and you just gradually
build the whole outfit up.
MMM.
To show up and for Kwanzaa,
right to the NFL does not give a fuck.
Come the end of the year. They
like, we own all the weekends.
We're taking all the fucking money.
All right.
We're showing games on Saturday that we
thought were going to matter, but don't,
we're kicking off the NFL season
this Thursday. This Thursday.
The NFL season is back.
Ladies and gentlemen,
NFL football is back.
Okay.
And for the next 17 fucking weeks
with the bye week
I ever fucking long the,
the, the, the, the, the, the,
the fucking season is
now the regular season.
Okay.
I like to think that this country
can set aside all of the issues
that are weighing us down and we can lose
ourselves in the bread and circus that
is professional football.
And when does it start bill all?
What? Put it up. Put it on.
It starts Thursday night,
Thursday night with yellow
defending super bowl champions.
The Philadelphia Eagles.
Did you ever think you'd ever
hear that in your fucking life?
People of Philadelphia?
You know you didn't.
Okay.
Don't even act like you did.
Right? Where the fuck am I?
You guys are playing the dirty birds
down there and fucking
Atlanta. It's, it's,
it's the battle of the
birds this Thursday night.
This is the only Thursday game worth
watching for the entire fucking season.
You might not have asked
because this is the only
one with a fucking teams
didn't play four days earlier
and they're all banged up.
Yes.
The Eagles who will be
wearing green on green. Yes.
The Falcons will be wearing, I don't
know, black and red on black and red.
It's a home game for the
eagles. They're probably going
to bring the, the, the, the,
the championship flag up there.
And can you imagine how many people in
the city of Philadelphia are not going to
be able to time their alcohol intake to
when the flag is going to be raised and
they'll be in that little jail in
the Eagle's stadium looking out,
you know? Well, the police laugh at them.
The local cops as they play iron
maiden's Ryman, the ancient mariner,
right.
Some are combined Ryman, the ancient
Mariner with the of Monte Cristo. I'm on,
he's looking out the fucking his
jail cell and he could see the ocean.
You could see how free,
you know,
see the boats going by and
he was just sitting in there.
Um, and then later he got a
Gig on sesame street. Anyways,
it starts with the eagles and the falcons.
Now I got you. If you're asking yourself,
will this be a hangover game?
Are The eagles still celebrating?
Yeah.
Who am I? Patriots playing?
Tom Brady coming up,
one of his great games as
a pro against the eagles.
A lot of people forget that [inaudible]
taught, taught the fucking ball.
He threw for over 500 yards
in a Superbowl and lost.
Okay, now let's the patriots go
to the Superbowl again this year.
You tell me when the fuck that's
ever going to happen again.
Yeah.
Everybody talking about Joe Dimaggio,
Oh, oh 56 game hitting streak,
whatever. Anybody can fucking do. That
56 game hitting streak is, is uh, is
pretty, God dammit. Impressive. You know,
to the point, they literally were
writing songs, Jolt Tin, Joe Dimaggio,
whatever they were doing,
right?
President was paying
attention than anybody write
a fucking song with Tom Brady
threw for 500 fucking yards
and a goddamn super Superbowl.
People have thrown for half that much,
smoked a cigar and
paraded around with them.
He threw enough yards to win to fucking
trophies in one game and the man lost.
So everybody's sitting around going,
how it can Tom keep doing it?
He's fucking old and blah,
blah, blah, blah, blah. Okay.
And I'm sitting over here with no
more hair left on top of my head.
The pullout going,
the problem is not Tommy.
I would say it's our defense.
That's what I teach. I would say
that that was the fucking problem.
That was such a fucking weird game.
Um,
I would love to go back
and watch it at some point
and just try to figure out how there was
only fucking two plants are three pumps
. The whole fucking game. The
weirdest Goddamn game I've
ever seen in my life. Um,
it's like both on offenses showed up to
play and the e in the fucking defense
was just like this. This is a Superbowl.
I just can't get comfortable. Um,
what else we could, we got the
bangles or the bangles is, uh,
is Paul verse.
He calls them the bangles,
calls them the girl group there and he
calls the girl group the bangles. Okay.
But Paul Versey, he marches to the beat
of his own drummer is playing the cult.
Andrew Luck. And I'm gonna
tell you something right now.
I'm tasting right now by an Andrew Look.
All right.
If you're fucking sitting
there right in life,
keeps kicking you in the Dick and
you're landed face down in the dust,
you know, and you just don't want to
get up anymore. Watch Andrew Luck.
Take a fucking hit. It does give a
fuck. Gets up. He congratulates the gay.
Great job man. I'll probably be filling
that in my early fifties. Congratulations.
See on the next play.
I love that guy.
This is me actually saying something
popped positive about the Indianapolis
Colts. As much as I hate
him or say, all right,
Andrew luck the way he conducts himself
out there with such fucking class.
I see.
It actually actually transcends the fact
that he takes a paycheck from that corrupt
piece of shit that Flim flam the boss
hog or the fucking NFL.
Um,
anyways, the bills are playing the ravens.
This is what I got to be asking my,
if I'm a buffalo bills fan and I got my
face in a plate full of fucking wings
over at anchor bar or fucking Duffy's,
whatever the fuck you supposed to go.
I got to be asking myself,
is this the year where the
bills for the finally return
to their AFC championship winning glory?
Do the bills finally get back to
their peak going to a Superbowl?
Yeah.
Sorry. You know, I'm going to get
people in the AFC east. A lot of shit.
The Buccaneers and the saints,
uh, drew breeze, by the way.
Not a lot of people realize this guy.
He's second all time.
I think he's strong for more yards than
Tom Brady and nobody pays attention to
him. Who's, who's kidding, who?
He's not dreamy. Like Tom Brady.
He's not as tall as Tom Brady.
You know,
supermodels are not knocking on his door.
He is a regular Joe.
He's a family man,
you know,
and he's down there and [inaudible] a
fucking city that the devil is even scared
to go to. And he has gone.
He's been able to maintain
the, the, the fucking values
that he was, he was brought up.
And I would say that is actually more
impressive to me than actually the amount
of yards he's thrown in his
career were taken collars.
Yeah.
Patriots are playing the Texans.
Right.
And that fucking saint
quarterbacks coming back,
I already forgot everybody's names.
Was that kid from Louisville.
So Clemson animal,
the fuck he's from.
But um,
I know he's amazing and JJ watts is back.
So this should be an early test
for these delinquent patriots.
The 40 niners verse, the Vikings, I don't
even know what's going on over there.
Okay. Is Kaepernick still kneeling on
the ground? Kapnik doesn't have a Gig.
The Vikings, the vikings who
are at their peak right now.
Okay.
Doing what they do.
Come in,
fucking it up. Waiting to the next
season. And they are on the rope.
Can they finally,
can they finally turn the fucking corner?
What else? What else is going
on? The giants are looking good.
They got that maniac running
back from fucking Penn state.
They're playing the Jaguars,
the browns,
they got that fucking dude from
Oklahoma, right? Or that the other,
the guy on TV said was undrafted bl
and he went on his fucking show with an
undrafted will short. They got
this kid, little bit of swagger,
the Cleveland browns playing the Steelers
right out of the gate. Jesus Christ.
Those two cities don't even get a
chance to put their fucking feets up.
I cannot fucking wait.
I am taping all of these games.
And your Los Angeles Rams
versus the Oakland, soon to be
last Vegas Raiders. I mean, how great
a fucking game is that going to be?
That's the game right there.
That's the game of the week right there.
Rams first Raiders. As far as I'm
concerned. That's the one I want to see.
Oh, the 49 is have, what's his
face? Seattle's a Richard Sherman.
They got him coming back from the,
the, the fucking dreaded Achilles
tendon injury. See what he can do for
the 40 niners you know what I mean? Um,
all right.
There you go.
So good luck to all you guys
unless you're playing the patriots.
Um, and now let's talk college football.
How great was it? College football?
You know,
they were smart enough to not have all
those cupcake games the beginning of the
year. I mean, when I was growing
up, like September was a joke.
You get your football cad from your
bookie and what would they be saying?
It'd be just like Nebraska would be
favored by 59 against like Kent State and
you'd take Kenn state and then
like they would be up like,
like fucking 35 to nothing at the half.
And you're like tea they would cover.
Yeah.
Um, anyways, I watched my Lsu,
my adopted Lsu Tigers against the Miami
hurricanes and a good friend of mine is
a huge Miami hurricane fan to the point
that I actually root for the Miami
hurricanes because I'm friends with him.
Not that I was ever a hurricane fan,
I wasn't.
So he was playing my adopted Lsu Tigers.
His team was playing my team.
So I texted him before the game.
I said the Miami tropical depression,
you know,
like when they think it's going to be a
hurricane and then they downgraded to a
tropical storm. Well, the downgrade of
tropical storm is tropical depression,
I believe, according to the weather
that I looked up. So he's like,
fuck you man. So we bought him a
better rounded drinks, some cigar.
I can't even fucking remember.
And I gotta tell you right now,
I thought,
you know,
Lsu the entire time I've been a fan of
these guys since like 2008 when I moved
out here, 2007, 2008.
So 2007 when I came out to
La and I actually had time
to watch college football.
MMM.
And I'd like less Meyers and how he
would go for it on fourth down and trick
plays and all that shit.
And you know, and I just,
I wasn't going to just jump
on the Alabama bandwagon.
Isn't it amazing that they're
still at the peak 10 years later?
MMM.
There's still the team to beat. Uh, so I
was like, I'm going to go with these guys.
So I've been watching them for 10 years
and for 10 years we have not had a
fucking quarterback.
They were doing that awful thing,
like that old school college football
thing where it was just like,
this is a running down put
in the black quarterback.
This is oh passing down,
put in the white quarterback.
They were doing that shit
in the two thousands. Right.
Um,
yeah.
And then I think there they're all time
rushing leader was their quarterback,
you know,
which is not a good stat.
They've had these beats at defense. They
actually had Odell Beckham at one point.
My buddy was saying like,
what a fucking waste.
They had nobody to throw
it to throw it to them. Um,
so I'm watching the game yesterday.
This kid Joe Burrow I guess transferred
some from some other college.
Um, I was losing my mind watching this
guy. This guy's a fucking quarterback,
you know, people getting in
his face, giving them shit.
He's giving them shit back.
He's fucking, he's reading
the blitz, you know, he's,
he was doing all this type of
shit and I was all excited.
And then I was just like,
this guy has got to have like 250 yards.
He only had a hundred,
144.
That's how much the QB
position is suffered.
While I've been watching these guys,
uh,
that I was excited that there was a
guy in the middle of the third quarter.
I had 144 yards passing.
Um, and their new coach,
I hope I say his name right.
Uh, ed or Darren or Jerome,
I don't even know how to say his name,
but all I know is he's,
he's got that by you fucking accent and
he, he sounds like fucking Hulk Hogan.
He sounds like he's doing a wrestling
promo. I was waiting for me.
Let me tell you something brother.
Um,
I'll try and get you a clip of him and
he flips out and screams and yells at the
players add, uh, that reminds me of what
a football coach was when I was a kid. Uh,
Lsu for the most part
just handled 25th ranked.
Lsu just handled eighth ranked Miami,
tropical depression,
Miami hurricanes. And uh,
but in typical Lsu fashion,
they still scared me towards the end
when all of a sudden l a Miami started
coming back and then it was just like,
it was 33 to 17 with six minutes
left and Miami stopped him again.
I'm like, they are two drives in to
two point conversions. Touchdown.
Two point convergence away
from tying this fucking game.
Only Lsu could make me this nervous
after being up like 33 to 10 or some shit
like that. Um, but they held
on they want and all of that.
So I am excited.
Uh,
I know it's the first week of the season
before all you negative concept there
are going to be fucking,
you know,
you know, a little baby. My
baby was all over overrated
much.
You know,
like that's some sort of like that
people just hate people being excited.
Yeah.
Oh, well what are you happy
about? Something? How can I
fucking shit all over this?
MMM.
Anyways,
let's,
let's do some ad reads
here on Labor Day to you.
Oh, just in time for fucking football
season, I now remember people,
you gotta gamble responsibly.
What I love about these guys is these
guys to not hide behind the fact that they
are a gambling site. Like some of
those other ones way back in the day,
like this is a, this is a
game of skill. All right.
My bookie
bookie,
they're proud,
you know,
bike like a fucking fat actress going up,
accepting an award being like,
I know I look good, right? Same
thing. They're being brave right now.
Um, my bookie, you know, ever
since I started this podcast,
people have been asking me for advice.
I don't know why.
Asked me what team to bet on. The truth
is, I don't know who's going to win,
but if you think you know, you gotta
check, you got to check out my bookie.
I could've done that way. But at the
truth is, I don't know who's going to win,
but if you think, you know,
you got to check out my book,
he crushed it. Remember?
Yeah,
who you're betting on is just as
important as who you're betting with.
That's why I always tell people to bet
with my bookie, I didn't know I did that.
Trust me guys,
they're your best bet this season.
They've been in business for years,
have been getting great reviews online
and their mobile site is easy to use.
I'll tell you,
if you're gonna put your paycheck on a t,
this is the website that doe it.
I would only recommend a service to my
listeners that that's been good to me.
That's why I'm urging you to make your
way to my bookie. You when they peg,
that's how it works.
Why are they making this sound up like
the fucker doing some cubs scouts? Shit.
Listen,
you fucking degenerate gamblers.
Here's a fucking website that's not
ashamed that they're going to try and take
your fucking money. You think you can
beat him. Go to the fucking website.
They have been game living,
live better live betting Jesus bill
the most rewarding player parks in the
business and for you
fantasy guys out there, man.
All you guys on Unicorns
bet non fucking football.
You can even bet the over under on how
many fantasy points of player will score
each game.
Join now and my bookie will match your
deposit dollar for dollar use Promo Code
Bur bur to activate the offer.
Visit my bookie online today.
That's my bookie, m. Y, B, O, k, I. E.
And don't forget to use the Promo Code
Bar when creating your account to claim
up to $1,000 in free play. You
play, you win, you get paid.
Also, you play, you
lose, you don't get laid,
especially if it's your girlfriends money.
So please fucking bet responsibly.
I will be calling in
tomorrow to my bookie.
I believe it's seven o'clock
or eight o'clock at night. Um,
uh, Pacific time. All right.
I'll be calling in with my pics even
though I don't know what the fuck's going
on. I'll make you laugh is what I'll
do. All right? So if you want to gamble,
there's a place to go, but to
do it responsibly, okay? Don't,
don't be getting fucking crazy. All
right, frame. Bridge everybody. Okay.
You've been listening to this show.
You heard me talk about frame
bridge or at least read about it.
They made it super easy and affordable
to frame your favorite things from at
prints and posters to the travel
photos sitting on your phone.
Here's how it works,
you know,
and I just frame three of them from
France and London and we got him sitting
right under my TV and it looks great.
It's a little collage.
If you will just go to frame which.com
and upload your photo or they'll send you
a package to safely mail it in your,
in your physical pieces.
The fuck does that mean preview
your item online in a frame style.
Choose your favorite or get
free recommendations from
their talented designers.
They'll rub out of blue frame,
the expert team at Frame Bridge for
custom frame your item and deliver your
finished piece directly to your door ready
to hang instead of the hundreds you'd
pay at the framing store. Their prices
start at just $39 in all shipping is free.
Plus my listeners will get 15% off their
first order@framebridge.com when they
use my code bur bur give your personal
experience using frame bridge.
Ah,
I went to London and I went to Paris,
France,
and I showed my tramp stamp underpants.
And A, I took a couple
of pictures, you know,
with my wife in our beautiful
daughter in front of the loove
front of the Eiffel Tower,
right? My favorite place to,
uh, my favorite cafe, the MAG, um,
I'll rules [inaudible] no, it's not
over there. Where the fuck is it?
I forgot what street it's on.
And then I took one of me smoking a cigar
with my dad when we were in London and
I just had all of those framed.
And that's great because you know,
you take all these great pictures, they
stay on your phone and then, you know,
they ended up in some hard drive
and then you break up with somebody.
You forget the fucking hard drive. Make
sure your frame, your good ones, you know,
they get to look at too.
You're like, oh, that's right.
There are people in the world that
liked me. Um, get started today,
frame you photos or send the perfect
gift for weddings, birthdays,
and special event. Go to [inaudible]
dot com and use the promo coper.
You'll save an additional 15% off your
first order. Just go to frame bridge.com
Promo Code Burr F, r a m e, B R,
I d, g e. Dot com Promo Code Burr.
I wonder if people who like rob banks
ever take selfies with each other,
you know, just as a joke and then they,
well, he can't send it to frame bridge.
Well, they wouldn't know
what the fuck was going on.
They think they were a Halloween party.
Dawlish
no matter what you do in the bathroom,
stop jerking off to get ready.
Dollar Shave Club has everything you
need to look, feel, and smell your best.
They have amazing shower stuff.
Hairstyling products,
toothbrushes and toothpaste and of
course raises and shaved supplies.
You might shave your whole body
to get ready for a bike race.
You might have to shape your whole body.
Dollar Shave Club's executive
razor and shave can't help.
You might do your hair to get
ready for your soccer match. Well,
I don't play soccer and I, and I'm
fucking shake my head here. Um,
bogies by dollar shave club can
help you get your style right.
Bogies Huh? The thing is, no
matter what you do to get ready,
dollar shave club has everything you need
and right now you can't get ready with
an amazing deal on one,
on anyone of their starters.
Sets like the daily
essential started that,
but she can't go wrong with any of them.
Head over to dollar shave
club.com/burr to pick up your own DSC.
Started set for just five bucks
after your started set product.
Ship at a regular price and make
sure, yeah, check out their new video.
Two that's dollar shave
club.com/bar high dollar shave
club.com/burb all right, two more
reads. Oh, draft kings, everybody.
Oh they're not ashamed anymore.
Draft Kings football returns
Thursday night. What?
Put it up. Put it up and huge cash
prizes are up for grabs at draftkings.
The leader in one week,
fantasy sports for the season opener.
Draft kings is hosting a fantasy
football contest that just,
that's just $10 to enter and has a wa a
$1 million top prize on you guys on your
Unicorns with your fantasy teams.
But for a limited time,
if you sign up with the code Burp B,
you are our draft kings will give you
a free entry with your first deposit.
Single game show down is
the newest way to play.
Just draft six players
from Thursdays game.
Stay under the salary cap and see
how your team stacks up against the
competition,
puts your football knowledge to work,
and you could win 1 million bucks while
watching the season opener. You know,
I make funny fantasy guys,
but like that's actually really fucking
cool and I'm afraid to fucking do it
because I will become addicted and I'll
be like you guys and stop rooting for
teams and I'll start rooting for players.
It's the game within the game, man.
You don't even have to come
in first to be a winner.
There are two and a half
million dollars in total prizes,
which means thousands of winners.
Download the APP or go to draftkings.com
now and use the code [inaudible] to
sign up and make your deposit.
Where'd you do draft kings will give you
a free shot at 1 million bucks a this
Thursday.
That's
Promo Code Co Promo Code Bar only at
draftkings kings minimum $5 deposit
eligibility restrictions apply.
See draftkings.com for details.
And lastly, but not
leastly. Sorry, I fucked up.
The rest of that read my head
was actually, I've already
made the Burger patties.
Okay. Now next thing I'm going
to do in my cup to the tomatoes,
the lettuce have all the pickles
have everything ready to fucking go.
And this year,
for the first time ever,
I am going to do a practice burger just
to make sure my temperature is right,
to know how long. So for all the people
who want it, medium rare, medium, well,
well done, all of that fucking shit.
I made my patty small this year.
I made him Finn.
All right.
Better than Mcdonald's or old school
Mcdonald's. Not Quite. Wendy's. All right.
Right in the fucking wheel house.
Cause I used to work,
I used to work in a uh,
this place called the sable cafe
in um, and Cary, North Carolina.
I worked there, I swear
to God, 31 years ago.
I worked there for nine months and
unfortunately the restaurant was gradually
going out of business.
I was a busboy and then I became
the bus boy and dishwasher.
And then at one point I swear
to God I was the grill chef,
the bus boy and the dishwasher.
As I took on these extra jobs,
they would give me like a 50 cent
raise and I was so bad with math,
it never dawned on me like, hey,
minimal wage is 350 an hour and, and,
and the dishwasher was getting paid 350
an hour and I was getting paid three 50
an hour.
So you paying two people $7 an hour to
do these two jobs and now I'm doing both
jobs. That other person doesn't have
a job and I'm only making $4 an hour.
Yeah.
Then I became the grill chefs and I think
I was making four 75 an hour or five
bucks an hour to do three fucking
jobs. And I would be out there and, uh,
I would be,
I was glassed in on a mesquite grill with
the chef hat and underneath my apron I
had the bow tie fucking, um, busboy
outfit. It was literally like, you know,
when Peter Brady had two dates
in one night, right. And, um,
I fucking wood duck down when I
saw a table almost done eating.
And I would run out there,
busted table, run back,
throw out the dishes in the
dishwasher and then run,
fuck it back out without washing my hands.
It's just food.
But you still,
you know,
I'm just handling your food and then
I would continue fucking cooking.
MMM.
And that, that's when I
learned that little trick.
You know, where you, you know,
I learned it this way. You
put you, if you put your, uh,
you just touch your thumb to your index
finger and then touch the fleshy part of
your,
uh,
of your hand that connects to your thumb
and you press on that, that's rare.
Then you just move it
to your middle finger.
That's like medium rare
than the ring fingers. Well,
and then the fucking pinkies well done.
Now that's fucking works.
Provided you do the in, and I'll put it
all depends on how thick the patty is,
an how high your fucking heaters.
So you gotta balance all of that out so
you can use that because that actually
fucking works unless you heats up too
high and your meats too thick and then you
think it's well done and all you did
was chatty the outside and inside,
it's a fucking Friday the 13th.
So I'm going to do that and have myself
a tasty fucking burger before anybody
even arrived.
I'm going to have my timer.
I'm going to adjust my
fucking heat and I'm going to,
I'm going to be ready full fucking
Freddy. You know what I mean? That's,
that's my deal here. Okay. That's how I'm
doing it and I'm going simple this year.
Burgers and dogs. Fuck
you, but you don't like it.
Get the fuck out this country.
I'm not smoking anything.
I'm not fucking,
I'm not doing any of this bullshit.
Burgers and dogs.
We got potato chips.
We have the standard fucking
condiments, lettuce, tomato,
pickles, ketchup, onions,
mustard. All right,
now fucking Asian infused fucking
this or Italian influenced that.
Oh, Billy ballgame. I'm going the
fucking, I'm going old school.
We got cheese. What kind of cheese you
want? You want the white or the yellow?
We don't have any margin.
We have butter
on toast in the bunch unless
you tell me otherwise.
All right,
that's it.
Can you feel my anxiety? All
right. stamps.com everybody.
The U s postal service is an
important tool for any business.
stamps.com is the easiest way to access
all the amazing services of the post
office.
I don't know why,
but I feel like over in annunciating
this whole read stamps.com never closes.
Print postage for letters or
packages at your convenience.
24 seven print postage for any male
class right from your own computer.
Buy and print official US postage
for any letter, any package,
any class of mail using your
own computer and printer,
they'll send you a digital scale automatic
that automatically calculates exact
postage stamps.
Dot Cam.
We'll even help you decide the best
class of mail based on your needs.
No need to lease an expensive,
expensive postage meter,
and there are no long term commitments.
I use stamps.com because include
your personal recommendation.
Whenever I send out my fucking posters.
Dude,
I use stamps.com I'm a
moron if I could do it,
so can you absolutely know negative
references, the Post Office, Oh my God,
I Wish I could cook a Burger for people
at the post office and right now you too
can enjoy stamps.
Dad Cam service with a special offer
that includes a four week trial plus
postage and a digital scale.
Go to stamps.cam.
Click on the microphone at the top of
the homepage and type in Burr that stamps
dad cam, enter burr. All right.
That was my nod to people in the Midwest.
Bob,
go to stamps.com in order minority,
their butcher box.
I'm speaking of butcher backs,
butcher box pork and ATC a festival.
That's right.
The all things comedy festival is um,
is uh, is coming back to Phoenix. It's
coming back to Phoenix in October.
Hey, and by the way, and I will
be there doing a live podcast.
This is a pre fucking promo.
Okay. I don't have any dates.
Shit. I'm just letting you
know. Keep your October open.
It's October 20 something
I believe. Um, anyways,
Shit's probably already on sale.
I don't even know.
Speaking of other things
that I need to promote,
I did a movie last year
called the front row.
All right.
And um,
the trailer starring Hugh Jackman,
the trailer who's already
getting Oscar Oscar buzz,
he's getting Oscar buzz old freckles. All
right. And I actually made the trailer,
um,
you realize how much I'm moving up in
the world that I'm actually in the movie
trailer. Now, I'm not saying that
if you drop a piece of popcorn,
you look down and kick it under the seat
in front of you that you won't miss me
in the trailer.
I'm just saying that I am in it for a
second with one of the best actors of
today. Who is getting Oscar
Buzz Repeat Oscar buzz.
Um, this weekend I'm going to be in, um,
some casino north of,
uh,
the hell's in Sacramento.
And then the next day on going to the
Toronto Film Festival for the Premiere of
the Front runner starring Hugh
Jackman who's getting Oscar buzz.
Okay. And then, um,
in the movies directed by the
Great Jason Raymond, by the way,
if you want to fucking win an Oscar,
okay.
It's starting to become
work with all freckles here.
All right?
We had to Oscar winners last year,
two or three from,
fromF is for family.
Fucking Sam Rockwell wanted,
Alison Janney won it.
I think Laura dern guy like a golden
globe. I don't watch award shows. Okay.
I don't have time. I'm busy focusing on
things that don't matter like sports.
Um,
and now we'll look what happens.
I have about seven lines in this movie
and all of a sudden, not coincidentally,
Hugh Jackman is now nominated or when
I was getting Oscar buzz I should say.
Okay,
and why is that?
Because he's unbelievably talented
because he puts the work in because he's a
pro. Maybe, maybe, but I think
more so
is that he had half a scene with
me. I think that's what it is. See,
once I go in the scene and they see what
I look like and where my acting is deck
at, right? I'm going to set
hack and act at the same time.
Then whatever you're doing as the other
actor is just going to be so fucking
elevated, then all of a sudden you're, you
know, you're going to be in the running.
Okay. And that's what I bring
to Hollywood. All right,
put your box everybody and the all
things comedy festival or by the way,
congratulations to Jason Reitman and Hugh
Jackman for getting all this great and
everybody else sits in the fucking movie,
you know,
forgetting all this awesome reviews,
which is a very hard thing to do this
day in age with all the cans out there in
the Internet. It's really difficult to
try to get some sort of positive feedback.
Um, and I'm, I'm, I'm just happy
just to be a small part of it.
You know what I mean? I'm like, Bill
Walton when he joined the Celtics. Okay,
my feet are fucked up.
I'm just happy, you know,
every once in awhile throw it to
me and I'll get a couple of points.
The crowd would go nuts because I
am on the scoring sheet that that's,
that's where I'm at. Butcher your box
pork at the all things comedy festival.
Hey Bill, huge fan. Just
writing into, thank you for
the butcher block. Block plug.
I'll listen to this. This dude tried the
pork shop that I've been raving about.
The heritage bread. Fucking pork. Okay.
You talk about the pork chops,
you talked about the port
trucks and how great they were.
So I had to get my hands on them.
My wife, who is an amazing cook,
seasoned these chops so well
I have to share it with you.
She put extra virgin olive oil
on them and salt and pepper.
Then let them rest for like 45 minutes.
Look at that.
I mean that's about as standard
of rub as you could possibly get.
That's all you have to do.
About a half a teaspoon per chop.
Then she just cooked them in
the oven for like 25 minutes.
You said the over cook them in the
over for like 20 to 25 minutes.
I'm assuming that meant of it bill.
It was the best goddamn pork chop
I ever had. I fucking told you.
He goes, when you get a cheat
day, uh, try that recipe. Uh,
thanks again. Can't wait to see you
in Phoenix in October. So I guess the,
the tickets are already on sale.
Um, yeah guys, I'm telling you,
man, who fucking knew that there was
a pure bred fucking pig out there,
which bloodlines can be traced
back to the original white people,
the Oh gee whities over there
in Europe. Um, I'm telling you,
I did mind differently. I took
out a black skillet and, uh,
I got that heat going, right?
And I, I, I forgot what I, I,
I don't even know what I put on the
fucking thing. I probably didn't know.
And me German,
Irish guy that I am,
I seared both sides and then I finished
it in the oven and then I brought it out
and I did a, like a rosemary,
uh, butter bath. Ugh.
I mean, I didn't even need a fucking
side who's every bite I took?
I was just punching the
fucking table. It was, it's,
it's that fucking good. All right.
If you're a kind of war there,
you gotta get the fucking heritage bread,
pork.
They're not even paying me for this.
This is how fucking good at is all right.
Urban mayor,
although that's a real slick way to get
some fucking a advertising in for free.
Be Somebody that fucking writes
in with their own experience. Uh,
urban Myer or Mayer.
How would spelled is that John Mayer?
But it's urban Meyer.
Is it John Meyer? Hey,
Billy Beluga whale.
What are your thoughts about
urban Meyer and the Osu scandal?
Do you think he should have
been fired? Uh, you know,
I stopped falling that he gets fired
over that. What the fuck was this?
Is this jerseys again?
Urban mayor fired reason let we go.
Bump,
bump, bump bomb. Boto
why is urban Meyer, uh,
he suspended. It doesn't
say, oh, he's not fired.
He suspended.
He's gonna say Jason Law head would have
been fucking tweeting all in capitals
at the whole fucking world. Maybe he
was. Why is urban Meyer's suspended?
Here's the short and the long answer.
I'll state suspended urban Meyer,
uh,
for the first three games
of Ohio state's 2018 season.
Who the fuck did he play in fuckhead you?
Is that this is the non
suspension suspension.
He's misses the Buckeye season
opener against Oregon state.
A likely blow out win for weeks
two and three against Rutgers.
Another likely blow out when and Tcu a
tougher game and a trip to Texas tec use
kind of fell off while we happened
to tacy. You come up from, um,
mayor can coach during the week before
sitting out the game itself off offensive
coordinator. Ryan Day is acting head
coach while Meijer is out. Yeah.
And he has a headset on the whole game.
Ci.
Who the fuck you think he's talking to?
Uh,
the short reason for the
head coaches suspension, uh,
school commission investigation decided
he mishandled domestic abuse allegations
against his former receiver's coach Zach
Smith. Oh, this is a little more serious,
but they didn't think,
is it bill?
Is it a little more serious than fucking
players selling their own jerseys?
But they didn't think mayors conduct
was egregious enough to merit firing.
One of the most successful
coaches in college history.
Subtext a was only one broad.
All right,
we got a national championship with
this guy. A below is the longer reason.
A recap to the details smiths.
Now ex wife Courtney Smith has repeatedly
accused him of domestic violence going
back to 2009.
So how does this fall on on urban Meyer?
He supposed to be a fucking cop.
Two,
2009 Zach Smith,
then a staffer on Meyer at Florida,
went to a party at Meyer's house.
Smith came home with a woman,
coworker who had been drinking and
planned to have her stay on Smith's couch
according to investigation. All right.
It sounds like a standard party.
They said Courtney Smith strenuously
objected and drove the woman to her home
that began a disagreement.
Courtney's called nine one one and alleged
that Zack picked her up and threw her
against the wall.
Police arrested Zach for Acra aggravated
battery and later dropped the charge.
Meyer says Zack and Courtney met with
them at his Florida office and told him
Zach's arrest was based on false
information. Courtney gave to the police.
Yeah.
In other words,
she told the fucking truth and then when
they fucking sobered up or calm down,
they were like,
this could cost us a lot of money.
Don't do it again and
we'll say that I lied.
Courtney denies that she
attended that meeting.
And Zach also recalled a to Osu as
investigators that she wasn't there.
Okay. So he sounds like he's lying,
uh, to the investigative team.
Courtney Smith denied
recanted her allegations.
She has never walked back any
allegations in public interviews either.
All right.
No charges were ultimately filed
against Zach for the 2009 incident.
Um, yeah cause they were working for
a big university when Meyer, well,
how does this go on urban Meyer?
Mayor Meyer hired him at Ohio state in
2011 a university background check didn't
turn up and arrest my,
I didn't tell anyone else at Ohio state
about it because he told investment
charges weren't filed and he didn't
think Zach had actually committed any
domestic violence between
October and November, 2050. And,
and what's the show that
he even saw this shit? Um,
in October and November,
2015 police twice went to court on the
home to investigate abuse allegations
against Zach to this one is
deals with, it's like, well,
you just fucking break up already.
Um,
that year Courtney texted with
Mayor's wife Shelly about Zach.
Shelly expressed sympathy and fear
for Courtney and in our own message.
And Courtney has said,
Shelley told her,
she informed the head coach about
Courtney's allegations. Yeah,
but she could have been
lying. You know, both mayor
Meyer maintain to Osu investigators that
Shelly never did inform urban about the
text messages. But Meyer has
acknowledged both in a public statement,
early August and two investigators that
he did know of an allegation in 2015
I don't
understand it. So what? So he knows
about it. So call the fucking cops
like I don't understand
like why this is on
the football fucking program.
They are,
they are not the cops. They are
not judges. They are not juries.
This whole fucking thing now where like
the judge and the jury and all of that
shit is now on social media and all
of this shit. It's fucking, I don't,
I don't get this.
It's like if he fucking did something,
call the cops.
The cops go there,
they fucking arrest him and
he fucking goes to jail.
I don't understand how the cops go there.
I recanted it. No, you didn't. All right,
we dropped the fucking charges,
but then the cops dropped the charges,
but then the school is supposed to go.
No, but you're still fucking guilty.
I don't know.
I mean, unless he was there
and saw him doing that shit,
what the fuck is he supposed to do?
This is why you have cops.
This is why the cops don't
coach a football team. Um,
I dunno. I have no idea. I don't,
I don't get that. I get that. Um,
if the university fired that guy,
you know,
I don't get why urban
mayor Meyer,
why that guy gets dragged into this shit.
I mean, if he was beating the shit out of
her at, at a fucking football practice,
and I guess urban was there going,
hey, settle down, settle down.
Nothing to see here. And I guess
he implicated himself. Bye Bye.
That, I mean, I don't, you know, I mean
the t visa,
these are fucking adults here.
That guy knows he's not supposed to be
beaten up his fucking wife. He's an adult,
so he should pay the fucking price.
I don't get why this guy has to now.
You know what I mean? When some gold
digging whore, fucking, uh, you know,
take some guy's house. Uh, does she
go to jail? Does she lose her job?
Does her friend that knew she was a
gold digging hoard is she then lose her
fucking position in the fucking world?
I, I don't get it. It's just, it's just,
it's just like, it's a fucking
one side of the street here.
If a guy does something to a
woman that he shouldn't be doing,
not only is he going to get punished now
everybody around them is going to get
fucking punished. But if a woman does
something, do a guy, eh, it's all right.
Everything's fucking fine. It's
fucking bullshit. That's what I say.
I think it's fucking bullshit.
If they are doing this on both sides of
the fucking fence, if you could sum up,
prove that this guy actually
fucking knew this shit. Granted,
I'm just going off for one website here.
All right.
From what I read on the Internet,
which doesn't mean shit. Now,
what do you guys ask me these fucking
questions? All right. Dancing. Hey Bill.
I'm a 16 year old kid from Minnesota,
Minnesota,
and I'm starting my junior
year in high school week.
I'm not a loser and I'm not the coolest
kid either. I'm right. Yeah. Here you go.
You're in the middle.
That's where I was.
I feel like I'm being held
back by my inability to dance.
What do you go to fame? High School.
It's not that I don't have rhythm.
I play three instruments.
My Band leader told me to dance
like I was playing an instruments.
The problem is I never know what to do
with my hands and I can't exactly be
playing air sacks at dances this year.
I really don't care that much.
It's just that I know I can dance,
but I haven't figured out moves yet all.
Then start dancing there, buddy.
Go on the fucking Internet.
I'll go on the Internet right now.
Find your fucking video and then practice
by yourself and do it in the mirror
like the chicks do, right?
All right. You Tube, you tube.
You can dance to. All right. Search.
Yeah.
Basic dance moves to not look stupid.
I just felt stupid with an e at
the end. What the F was to be. Eat,
how to dance with confidence.
Not Look like a Dork.
And I gotta tell you this
Guy Club dance moves for men.
How to not look stiff and
awkward. Bam. There you go.
There we go.
A three minute video after this fucking
stupid Goddamn guy tells me about grape
nuts standing on a fucking mountain.
Somehow we just started running naked.
How to dance for men.
It's an Asian kid with the cool hat. You
know he's going to be good. There you go.
Bam. The name of this video
is club dance moves for men.
How to not look stiff and awkward
for beginner. All right dude,
I found that in two fucking sec. Second.
All right. There you go. There you go.
You're in.
So just fucking do that for awhile
till it's second God damn nature.
Put a little stank on your face and Eh,
you know,
pump up fucking couple drinks and
yourself, not on a, you're under age. Uh,
you'll be fine. You'll be
fine. Just do it. Learn how to,
how did you learn how to get
good at saxophone? Did you
sit there going, you know,
I know I can play saxophone, but you
never did it. Just go out and do it.
You'll be fine. All right.
Solo, fucking POW. Dear bill,
this old house, I'm a home owner
like yourself and like yourself.
I looked into solar power.
Hey too. Not from nothing.
I want to be a candy or do you
have you paid off your house?
Cause if you haven't paid off your
house, you're not a homeowner. All right.
What you own is the debt on the house.
Okay. I hate when people go, oh you,
you ran home. I am now.
You're dumb. You don't know.
You don't own it until they give it to
you that they'd fucking goddamn piece of
paper. Sorry. And like yourself.
I looked into solar power bill.
When I tell you I spent over 200 hours
reading up on solar and talking to
different installers.
I'm telling you the truth.
I had zero luck finding
anything that made sense. Yeah,
I think there's a lot of taxes and shit.
There's a lot of oil and coal kind
of jockeying against shit. Um,
the more research I did,
the more discouraged I got.
I went in thinking there was no way I
wouldn't come out with some type of solar
panel subsidizing the energy I use.
Yeah.
Now they do this thing
with the electric company.
They used to buy back your power.
Now they just claim the shit that you
don't even use. Um, I hate to be cynical,
but I feel like solar is useless
until the technology gets better.
I don't know if you've ever
followed through, but I was
hoping to get an update.
Um, I don't think it's
useless. I understand. Um,
anything that is going to help us
slow down fucking global warming
is going to be an asset if you can't
afford to do it. I understand. Um,
I have not done it yet.
Um,
I keep telling my wife I want
to do and she's this like,
this is going to be loud and it's just
like, you know, I would love to do it.
Um, I have some Spanish style,
not are on all the whole roof.
My roof is flat and then this
little lip of Spanish tiles,
but like a Tesla is allegedly
coming out with those,
those Spanish tiles that
are also solar powered. Um,
I mean, that fucking guy is like
actually addressing what's going on.
And I wish there was a way that he could
fucking hire coal miners to fucking
work in the solar industry so they didn't
have to take away 30% of our beautiful
public parks to continue
using this fucking form of
energy that is fucking with
the planet. That, but for
some reason you're not allowed
to bring it up if you do.
You're crying snowflake.
MMM,
I dunno. It's, it's
okay.
I have no idea. And I have not read up
as nearly as much as you have a, I have,
I have not even overheard as much
as you've probably read on it. Um,
I'll read up on it. I should do
it. I would love to do it. Um,
you know, but I just, every time
I fucking go to do something,
I'm fucking something in my house.
I only tell you guys what I'm
fucking dealing with right now.
I don't even want to fucking fill you.
What on fucking deal with that here.
Have you ever heard a roof?
Rats.
Yeah.
Roof rats.
Uh,
evidently somehow some we have a crawl
space between our roof and you know,
you can't stand up, but it was enough that
these fucking mice got up there and I,
we have an exterminator come up there.
You know,
God knows what they did in the walls.
Thank God they didn't chew through
any fucking wires. And uh, you know,
so then I got to go up there and you know,
get rid of the dead mice.
That's my life. Okay.
Sobriety. Hey Billy Bama set.
Okay.
I'm a 27 year old male and I just wanted
to truly say thank you for helping me
onto the wagon of sobriety.
Forget the past few months,
every as you started listening to your
podcast and have heard you bitch and moan
the whole time about being
sober from drinking. This
made me think to myself, hey,
if this can, this, this
can can do it. So can I.
It's been a few weeks now and I've been
clean from drugs and alcohol and I've
never felt better. Yeah, it was
fucking amazing. None living a clean,
I mean at night it sucks that
that's when you get squirrely,
but if you just fucking pushed through
it and you wake up in the morning stone
sober, it's like you feel like
you've compared to, you know,
being hung over and shit. And I never
even fucked with drugs other than alcohol,
which is a drug in all fairness.
Um,
you feel like an eight year
old when you wake up. He says,
I don't have friends because they're
dead beat drug addict, losers.
Everyday at my job I lose.
I literally listened to eight hours
of the podcasts a day. Um, see, see,
you're learning how to take your addictive
personality and Admin pointing it at
shit that's more positive. Hopefully
this positive is more pod positive.
So in a sense, you're my only
friend, so thanks for that as well.
Thanks for helping me through these
trying times and I really look forward to
maybe seeing your set at one of your
Chicago shows in November. Hey, you know,
I was hanging out Friday night with a
buddy of mine who's been sober for nine
months and he just wanted to do it
for a month, but just after a month,
all this shit that
you've been putting off,
all of a sudden he started
getting shit done. He said,
I'm going to go two months and
now he's just staying sober.
He was saying just out of superstition
that I don't want to go back to that and
um,
that's a great thing.
So I'm going to try to go September
without drinking today. I have,
I have,
my big cheat thing is I have a
glass bottle of grape Phanta,
um, that I am going to have, um,
with my burger and then I'm right
back on the wagon, but a pretty,
but I'm going to be eating,
you know,
eating healthy the rest day. I hate that.
No Jane, when people say I'm eating,
I've been eating clean.
Yeah.
I like, I, I just, I don't
like that now. You know,
just clean eating and eating clean.
Okay.
It's like you don't even know
what the fuck you're reading.
I go to these farmer's markets and you
have no idea where this shit came from.
There's nobody down there like I've heard,
like the FDA basically
polices like 3% of the food.
You have no idea where the fuck it
came from. You have no fucking idea.
You have no idea what it's been
sprayed with and all of that shit.
But it says organic and it
gets in your fucking head. Ooh,
I'm leaving fucking clean. You have no
fucking idea unless you grew it yourself.
Um, dilemma. Um, all right,
dear Billy Brown belt,
would you rather be forced to eat protein
bars every meal for the rest of your
life or eat one meal every four days?
MMM.
Can I survive?
Can I survive eating one
meal every four days?
I don't know if you could survive
doing that bad. That's a good one.
No, I'd rather you want
me to let me four days.
I think it'd be more healthy
than those protein bars.
Cause you don't know what the
fuck's in those things either.
You mean you flip that thing over like a
Django. Anyone thinks fucking overrated,
GNC,
all those powdered fucking
chemicals like that Maca powder.
Every time I put that in there and go,
what the fuck is this shit?
You know,
the plant protein powder and all that
at Cisco, we'll go eat a fucking plant.
Um, anyways, number two, all
right. Now the dilemma, um,
I wouldn't want to be Billy Clif
bar for the rest of my fucking life
cause once every four
days I could actually, uh,
I could actually have something
that I liked, you know,
chicken and dumplings, some shit
like that. Something really fancy.
Maybe there'll be like having a death
row fucking meal every four days.
Yeah, that would be
tremendous. Um, as long as you,
I could do that in a healthy
way. Yeah, I would do that.
You get used to that quick. Um,
number two, you're going to die,
but you can save your life if
you succeed at one of two things,
which do you have more
confidence in doing successfully?
Having one year to study and get a perfect
score on the sats? Yeah. Fuck that.
Or come in first place
in a game of monopoly.
I have one year to come in first
place in a game of monopoly.
How many games can I play?
Um,
is it a monopoly tournament?
My playing with a bunch of old ladies
that have been playing since the fucking
depression and they're going
to kick my ass. All right.
Having one year to study and get a perfect
score on the sats. You know what, Dude,
I would love to try to do that
and it would take me way more than a year
with the math.
Um, all I know is that
I took a college, uh,
sat prep course and I still got,
I got a three something combined.
I'm not even fucking lying to you guys.
Like I, that sounds like a joke, but I,
I mean you, they'll give you like to be
an employee just to sign the paper. Yeah,
I know.
I forget what I got. I got, did I get
a four, 10 or a three 90? It was bad.
And I remember getting
laughs at my sat score.
Yeah.
That's how, you know,
that's how I always did.
I was fucking made fun of myself and
I, and I got laughs. So I actually,
I remember I didn't give a shit. I
never gave a shit. I always kind of,
I always kind of had this feeling and
I was going to do all right in life.
You know, I had an overall
positive outlook despite
everything that I was doing.
You don't have two years of a language.
Yeah.
Y'All is fucking stupid shit. You
know what I mean? That's not a,
life is not about those things. All
right? I'm not saying don't try,
don't fucking try to do well
on the thing and all that shit.
I'm not fucking saying that.
Well, what are you saying, bill?
I'm just saying that there's, there's
a million ways to skin a cat. Okay.
How the fuck did that come about?
Huh? I gotta look that one up.
It's more than one to skin a cat,
right?
Yeah.
There's more than one
way to skin a cat origin.
Okay.
An early appearance is in way down east.
Fuck Jesus Christ.
Well, what, what? Okay. Etymology of the
phrase, this more than one, more than one,
which you know, so many times when you
look these up, it's just not satisfying.
MMM.
Yeah.
So there's actually only two ways to
skin a cat while it's alive or while it's
dead. Well, I mean,
you could also start at the head.
You could start at the back.
Didn't want to say the ass.
There are two ways. One,
one of them is you skin a cat
because you are a bad person.
The other is you don't skin a cat.
You are a nice,
or the cat never existed.
The third one,
weight is both you skin a cat and
at the same time you don't scan it.
Yeah.
Okay.
This is just people writing.
I find your use of boiled down
in this context disturbing.
You knew this would, this would bring
out all the fucking animal lovers. Right?
Let's see if there's any comments from
the fucking Peta people, PT people, Peta,
Peta people.
There's more than one way to skin.
A cat is not referring to the removal
of flesh from our feline friends,
but rather a phrase that originated
from the Mississippi River region that
pertains to the preparation of a catfish.
Oh,
oh,
well, maybe that's what it is. I have
no idea. I don't fucking know. Anyways,
that's the podcast.
Happy Labor Day to y'all.
Happy Labor Day to you. Woo. Woo.
I'm fucking check in on you this Thursday
day.
Hey,
go fuck yourselves and enjoy your day.
Uh,
fuck it.
Um.